a powerful symbolic moment china's
president xi jinping arrived by
high-speed train
at a station that's been closed for two
and a half years because of covet 19.
it was a carefully choreographed welcome
that included many citizens from
mainland china it'll be a quick visit
and in a short address the president
said he'd been thinking a lot about hong
kong
hong kong endured difficult tests one
after another
overcame risk challenges one after the
other
after these storms
hong kong re-emerged from the fire and
was reborn
it's the president's first visit here
since protests three years ago when
hundreds of thousands of people took to
the streets demanding political reform
on friday the president will attend the
swearing-in ceremony of hong kong's new
chief executive john lee
that coincides with the 25th anniversary
of hong kong's return from britain to
china until a few days ago it was still
unclear whether xi jinping would be
coming at all that's because of another
rise in the local covid19 infection rate
she last left mainland china in january
2020 before his zero covet policy closed
the country's borders including the one
with hong kong
there is a strong patriotic theme for
this anniversary communist party-style
slogans exhort people to celebrate 25
years of chinese rule the symbolism is
everywhere
security is extensive water barriers
deployed once more as they were during
the unrest in 2019
the police now control these streets
a job made easier by the imposition of a
national security law that's led to the
arrest of more than 150 people
it poured with rain during the handover
25 years ago and it did so again on
thursday a tropical storm bearing down
on hong kong
just as the president arrived
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong